foreign
all right we are live on the internet
we're at the local Studio here in Miami
I'm still Dave Rubin it's still the
Reuben report and it's not a great day
for America but I do have a fantastic
guest with me for this bonus show we did
our live show this morning we haven't
done two live shows in the same day in a
couple years but sort of seemed like
today was the day to do it and sitting
next to me as a Fox News contributor and
host of the truth with Lisa booth on I
heart radio and most importantly my
friend hi Dave I know we've been trying
to do this but it has to be like one of
the most depressing things
now just come on when there's a World
War when that gets started we'll do that
day as well because I'm pretty sure
World War III starts sometime in July
um but the timing of this is sort of
bizarre because we wanted to sit down
with you forever there were a couple of
logistical things we couldn't work out
so we've had this booked for a while and
we were going to pre-tape it and then
release it next week and then I was like
this morning I was like we have to go
live because was Lisa Booth people can
say a lot of things about Lisa Booth
they can't say she isn't outspoken thank
you I didn't know where this is
[Laughter]
I was going to do a proper interview
with you like the Lisa Booth story and
all of the stuff and what and because
you're also a new Floridian transplant
all that stuff so we're going to do that
another time most of my audience knows
you already Fox News they see you on all
this stuff you want to just say anything
about yourself and then we're just going
to talk to them anything else or someone
that's never seen you before that is
going my God Lisa Booth who is this
woman check out my podcast the truth
with least Booth I'll get a plug in
there and no I I really tried it look I
I think we're sort of living in an age
of cowardice where a lot of people are
afraid to speak the truth they're afraid
to say what they really should be saying
because look we live in this social
media you know culture where basically
like this mob mentality and people try
to beat you down and get you to to
submit to the will of you know the
broader narrative and the group thing so
I try to kind of get to the bottom of
stuff on my podcast and have some
conversations that maybe you don't see
you know that many other places and you
live it you don't just say it because
you were very proudly unboxed we are
both unvasked yeah actually everyone in
this room is on back that's very
exciting uh but it's it's cost you gigs
and jobs and and kept you out of studios
and and a whole bunch of stuff so uh you
do walk the walk too is what I'm trying
to say here yeah I mean look there was a
period where we can go out to dinner in
New York City right we were crucified
for for not wanting to get vaccinated
and that's really you know kind of makes
you understand where we are today in
this day and age where you know with
Trump getting indicted I mean even then
you looked at the Rasmussen pulling
almost half the Democrats wanted to put
People Like Us in government camps give
them a chance yeah it's not true it's
not too late Dave but but like we
probably you know who knows which we
could have continued in the direction of
China if it hadn't have been for Omicron
and essentially everyone getting
deprogrammed because you had all these
people who thought somehow they were
never going to get covet who ended up
with covid and then they're like oh it's
not doesn't make you a bad person if you
get coveted like let's move on you know
but who knows what would have happened
otherwise that very white pill of you
that they that you know things got
better because you know they they are
going to bring it back when when they
need to but speaking I don't know if it
would be coveted but it'll be like it'll
be right climate or you know guys I mean
who knows they could create anything
right speaking of crucifixions though
um with Easter and Passover right here
let's just throw it to the video so if
you haven't seen it just in the last
half hour or so uh this is Donald Trump
entering the courthouse uh this is about
20 seconds or so there he is walking in
they didn't you see the way they didn't
hold the door for him like the guy
intentionally let it swing on him that
was the face the entire time there is
the picture he pled not guilty
um
fine give me your just sort of General
take on this and then we'll dive into
some of the specifics I mean I honestly
find it terrifying right I mean whether
you like Trump or you you hate them it's
not even really about Trump it's about
the bigger picture it's about the future
of the country and you you aren't a free
country if you don't have the rule of
law and I think we're sort of mourning
the death of the rule of law mourning
the death the due process mourning the
law or Mourning the death of the equal
application of the law with this because
we know that you've got someone like
Alvin Bragg the Manhattan D.A he
downgraded 50 52 of felony cases to
misdemeanors and now he's trying to
elevate maybe a misdemeanor to a felony
and meanwhile I mean you know how
dangerous New York City is right now
Dave I left New York you left California
for for a lot of the reasons crime all
these other things that were going on in
in these places and so he's fine with
people getting getting shot in the
street I mean there's literally
executions happening in in the streets
of in New York but this is what gets his
attention you know it's funny because
every time I go back to New York to do
usually something on Fox so Gutfeld or
whatever it might be we've been there
together at similar times and last week
last was it maybe three weeks ago we had
dinner in New York and we were both like
man this city is done and it has
something to do with the D.A who is no
pun intended trumping up the charges so
taking what technically would be
misdemeanors making them into felonies I
mean this guy oh and by the way he is
Soros funded he is so responded it's not
anti-semitic to say that Soros gave a
million dollars to the pack that helped
get this guy in office like that's just
a fact well it's also just depressing I
mean I mean think about like how hard
life is for so many Americans right now
you know you you can't put food on your
table you can't pay your bills
everything costs more with inflation and
it's intentional by the by
Administration rate increased spending
also uh you know trying to to not allow
things like make a you know Drilling and
for us to be able to be energy
independent here in America driving up
costs in almost every aspect so people
are feeling the pain of the economy and
then you've got you know the the
concerns about you know Biden trying to
instigate a World War as well you're not
safe in your streets particularly if you
live in Liberal cities like New York
and so that I think this is almost a
slap in the face to so many Americans
who are saying we've got real problems
right like life is not great for so many
Americans there's there's a heaviness
with everything going on in the country
but then this is what gets the left's
attention this is what they're focused
on right now it's not about making the
lives of Americans better it's about
trying to go after Donald Trump to try
to get this trophy which is the way they
view them and to put it on the mantle of
you know Alvin Bragg ran on this
and this is what he said in the Democrat
primary he ran on I'm going to be the
guy who gets Donald Trump
and he's not the only one remember when
Rashida Talib in Michigan the night she
got uh voted in she said I'm here to
impeach Trump I mean these people have
been doing this for a long time but
could it be do you think it's possible
like they got him now like this is
different this is different than
impeachment one impeachment two rate at
Mar-A-Lago all of the stuff like this
feels different I mean he actually just
pled not guilty he was in a courthouse
they dragged them to another state
whether it's a complete forest or not it
does feel different
this isn't it right he's facing that
investigation out of Georgia he's facing
Federal investigations as well and these
are criminal investigations that he's
facing so so yeah you know bigger than
impeachment bigger than these things
where you know he's not facing a
criminal investigation with that but he
is facing in Georgia obviously New York
City we're talking about it right now uh
and then also Federal as well and so I
think that's my concern is that look
these investigations have weight and
they've already made it known you
mentioned Rashida Talib we know that
Alvin Bragg has said that this was his
mission we know that this is the mission
of the left they want to destroy him
um so I I don't know that's a lot of
incoming fire that he's taking and real
incoming fire as well are you over the
intentions with these people that's sort
of what you implied a second ago that
that it's not good intentions like these
people are telling you what their
intentions are and they're going ahead
to it meaning that they're not they're
not just sort of like in over their head
and get into these messes but they're
here to actually jail former presidents
and scare the hell out of the rest of us
and tank the economy and and pretty much
everything else yeah I mean they went
after Mark Hoke
the pro-life Catholic uh he went and was
basically just trying to get a woman to
change her mind woman to change their
minds to not get abortions they arrested
him in front of his seven children uh
thankfully he ended up you know not the
uh grand jury in Pennsylvania decided
not to move forward for him so he's
going to be okay but you look what
they've done to the January 6 uh
protesters as well even during covet I
mean half of Democrats wanted to put us
in a government facility for not getting
vaccinated right so of course this is
the mindset of today's left or even look
at the fact that after the the
um murders in Nashville at that
Christian School innocent babies right
at the at the hands of a you know
domestic terrorist a transgender
individual what did Biden do this is the
day of you know yes whatever yeah and
they blamed it on Christians and they
try to elevate the the murderer right so
yeah I think that there's a sickness on
the left and this isn't just a one-off
in New York City this is sort of the
sweeping mentality of today's left
they're militant have you seen anyone on
the left or any of the few remaining
sane liberals and it's always fewer and
fewer as the days go by stand up for
Trump right now because we were looking
this morning I really because to me it
doesn't even matter if he did something
potentially illegal here the idea that
you're going to go after former
presidents we end up in an autocracy
over like it's begun in a certain way
once you say okay we're going to arrest
former presidents especially on
technicalities from years ago that have
nothing to do with government corruption
or what he did in office having to do
with a personal thing that he did before
he was president once you start doing
that you're basically saying to everyone
who would dare be president we'll arrest
you too so you may not want to give up
power like that's how this happens well
and I think that's sort of the intent
right I mean they don't want they want
people to be scared from running for
office they don't want us to have good
candidates and that's even just saying
that I mean you look at what the FBI did
in 2020 look at big Tech coming in and
not disallowing the sharing of the
hunter Biden story so we already know
that you know Republicans are fighting
with our hands you know at least one
hand held behind our back in an election
uh but you know even beyond that yeah I
think they're trying to scare off
conservatives from running for office
like look we did this to Trump we'll do
this to you as well and I honestly it's
probably working I mean don't you think
there are a lot of people who you know
maybe a decade ago would say I'm going
to run for office I want to make a
difference in this country and then I
think there's some people saying can I
even make a difference will it even make
a difference and then also my god do I
want to have to deal with this it's
interesting because on the show this
morning I was talking about how to get
into politics in the first place it's so
interesting it's so corrupt so you know
it's mine it is whiskey lipstick
we need it today
um that's how you know we know each
other like we need it today it's like oh
it was like of all days I'm going on
with you and it's like I just want to
sit in the corner and drink tequila and
be depressed but get a drink after this
let's do it yeah I think we're gonna um
but I was saying on the show today how
it's like politics already is messy and
they will come for you and they will
come for your family and in some ways
Trump shifted that when he first ran
because it was like he wasn't hiding
that he wasn't this perfect human that
he didn't have these relationships you
know he brought out remember the debate
when he brought out all of the women
that Bill Clinton in essence raped or
was accused of raping all that stuff but
now it's like they escalated that now
it's like we're not just going to go
into your past and find out what's what
skeletons are in your closet we will
post presidency arrest you like that's a
again that's just a big escalation well
it is but we've kind of seen it coming a
little bit to me even remember what they
did to Brett Kavanaugh yeah right I mean
you take a guy who like is such an nerd
that he kept his like high school
calendars yeah yeah who does right like
who I didn't even keep a calendar in
high school like it's like he's just
such a nerd and they turned him into the
serial rapist yeah like father of two
and then Christine Ford's attorney comes
out later saying that basically she was
driven by you know abortion on this we
know that her testimony and her
allegations don't check out factually
there were a lot of issues with it
factually you know she had talked about
some therapist notes we don't even know
if they've existed no one's even seen
them right
um so and then she lied about her fear
of flying she had a former ex-boyfriend
come out basically saying she's crazy
she's a liar you know sign that under
oath right so but they're willing to do
that and there are Democrats that knew
that it was bogus right and like I mean
even what she was I mean anyways the
whole thing was garbage but they were
willing to slander this man destroy his
life destroy his livelihood in front of
his wife and kids for politics do you
think that's what this is really about
in a weird way it's like they've gotten
away with so many lies about all of
these people and Jesse Smollett and this
you know I always go through the list on
the show I mean there is like we don't
have do we have time for that we don't
very fine people they've lied about so
many things like Hillary Clinton's
reasons for why she didn't win it's like
it's endless you know yeah she's an
illegitimate president but because they
can write about everything for so long
and gotten away with all of it I think
in some ways it's just like for the
machine and these machine people it's
just like well it's just lying in let's
just do whatever we can because nobody
ever stops us or pays the price so
is that you know how after Biden
I believe it was the withdrawal from
Afghanistan I don't necessarily disagree
with that it was the manner in which he
did it and the botched withdrawal and
the fact he got 13 service members
killed and just the chaos and leaving
all those weapons behind to the Taliban
sort of the embarrassing nature of it
you had all these Bad actors whether
it's Putin whether it's Kim donun
whether it's president XI all saying oh
okay now is the time right if I'm gonna
take Taiwan if I'm gonna try to you know
move forward with my Nuclear Ambitions
if you're Iran like now is the time to
do it under this guy because Joe Biden
showed his cards and I think we as
Americans showed our cards during coven
right I mean how many people just rolled
over yeah right they said go out and get
a yeah go out and get a vaccine that
might not be safe that you might not
even need for a virus that isn't a
threat to her life when you're still
going to spread it to other people but
you better go get it and you're going to
get a vaccine passport log it in on your
phone we're gonna track you you know and
then people just rolled over and they
said okay sure so if you're Gavin Newsom
if you're you're Joe Biden if you're any
of these Bad actors you know they're
saying oh I can do whatever I want to
these people I think we just got the
first photo of trump sitting before the
judge did it just come out I think we
got it right there that's that's Trump
in in Trump form with the lawyers around
him I mean isn't a portion of this also
just the the deal that seems to have
been made in Hell between Trump and the
media in some ways like if you think
about it Trump I think it was in
September announced he was running for
president again then we had like two or
three months of not much from Trump
there really wasn't much it was sort of
like oh did this thing run out of steam
and now it feels like they just they
just threw him the life raft like they
do need him because they want clicks and
Views and he is better than anyone for
that so it's like that feels like a very
very dangerous combo to me well I also
believe that I mean the Trump
derangement syndrome is real right like
we always talk about it sort of a joking
manner but it's real I mean the level of
hatred for this guy I mean that's that
is a real thing right like people you
could tell you could just give someone
blatant facts and they've already made
up their mind about this guy yeah they
either love him or or they hate him and
so I believe that you know you've got
the vast majority of the media really
hates this guy you've got Democrat
politicians really hate this guy and I
truly believe that they want to see him
in jail I mean how excited is MSNBC
today or CNN well they know they're
going to get views also so it's double
right it's like oh we could jail him
which is great we're jailing Hitler
we're such good guys and it's also like
oh and people are actually going to tune
in when generally people have been
tuning out of this nonsense but I think
they also just want it yeah right like I
think they just genuinely hate this guy
and they actually want to see him in
prison and I think we've reached a point
in politics maybe perhaps because of
social media or whatever it is where
like you've sort of this like social
contagion where you know everyone's just
like feeding off and it's like this
Feeding Frenzy right with this mentality
that we have as a country but you know
we sort of there's been like this
dehumanization of people
you know like this other ring of people
when we saw Drew Biden uh you know go
along with it when he stood on in
Philadelphia to labeling 75 million
Americans who supported Trump as
essentially domestic terrorists right
and we see it in the media as well with
Mitsubishi and CNN the way they talk
right it's like they don't I don't even
think they view Trump as a human being
yeah right like they've dehumanized him
to such a degree that
like I I don't even think they view him
as a human life what should we be doing
right now like for the average person
around here guys we're gonna see what we
can do but but like for the average
person that's watching this I think I
think part of the reason the machine
always wins is the average person is
kind of doing what you've mentioned
before like they have to have a job and
they want to live their life and they
want to watch TV and not worry about
everything all the time so the machine
just kind of moves on everybody all the
time because they know that people will
just allow their freedoms to disappear
they'll allow the symbols did you see uh
Glenn Beck was on uh Tucker last night
and one of the things he brought up yeah
well he brought up something that I
thought was really great he said he said
Trump is no longer a man in a way he's a
symbol and I think that's right it's
sort of like Christopher Nolan's Batman
thing like it's like Trump now
represents this thing and either are we
going to fight for it or against it
and clearly a certain amount of people
just won't care what the truth is well I
had right we talked a little bit about
that earlier with just the economy just
you know covet I think was really
harmful on so many I mean we saw it with
increased depression increased suicide
overdoses people dying from overdoses so
we saw it in terms of numbers and just
you know a matter of fact but I think
just with every right it really just
it just led to the heaviness in the
nation and so you know I I think and
then you loud on us all this other stuff
to it so I think people are somewhat
intentionally just kind of turning off
the TV putting their head down trying to
get through the day spend time with
their family because it's almost too
much you know if you're really I mean
we're in this right we have to be in
this and even for us in the media
sometimes when I'm not yeah sometimes
when I'm not doing TV or I'm not working
I turn it off I go for a walk I get
outside I spend time with my dog I try
to see my friends talk to my family
because if you're just in it 24 7 and
you're just paying attention it's too
heavy like it really is all just too
much and then you add on like personal
stuff that you know so many Americans
are going through just in their own
lives so I think to some degree maybe
people aren't seeing everything as they
should because it's just too much if you
really paid attention to it do you think
in some ways Trump brought a little bit
of this on himself by being so combative
with everybody for so long and and you
know getting rid of so many people and
making so many people enemies and even
in the last you know month or so I've
been very critical of Trump trump who I
liked I like and I voted for and I might
vote for again I'm more inclined to vote
for him now than I was probably a couple
weeks ago but all of the crazy stuff
with DeSantis that he's turned so many
people against him that he was in some
ways bringing this upon himself it's not
an excuse for it but just at some level
I mean I I think there's sometimes there
can be truth in a bunch of different
things right like sure do I believe that
Trump has brought some stuff upon
himself you know on tweets and just or
even you know going after Alvin Bragg
personally I mean I would have to assume
that if you're Alvin Bragg that only
feeds the Beast feeds the fire right
picture with the baseball bat yeah
talking about death and destruction on
the streets of New York City if they
indict him like these these things where
it's like yeah but but then I also
believe that probably the bigger driver
of it was the fact that you had a guy
that wasn't easily controllable right
and I think what we've seen in
Washington DC that's really sad is it's
not just democrats for the problem it's
also a lot of Republicans as well right
this you know people talk about a unit
party or whatever you want to call it
right it's the government bureaucracy
that's really working against the
American people and they're serving
their own interests they're not serving
ours and and so I think you got a guy in
Trump that really wasn't able to be
controlled you know he was really fueled
by the people and I believe he ran for
office in 2016 for the right reasons I
do believe that he's a patriot I do
believe he loves this country I do
believe that he thought he was the guy
to change it and he couldn't be bi you
know he'd be on stage being like yeah I
gave to Nancy Pelosi because I could buy
her like you know and everyone's like
all right yeah it makes sense you know
like so I think you had a guy with him
that couldn't be controlled and what
we've seen during covet what we've seen
even with this trans stuff they just
want you to shut up submit and bend to
the will of the party right whether it's
Democrats Republicans sort of this
Collective beasts that we're facing in
government and if you don't bend the
knee then they try to destroy you like
they did even with us during covet right
you can't go here you can't do this
we're going to make your life miserable
miserable and then some people on you
know CNN like that former Planned
Parenthood lady uh saying that oh she
didn't want us to be able to go to
grocery stores or even be able to do
little things in life they almost try to
stop us from being able to fly right and
it's because we didn't bend the knee and
so I think Trump didn't bend the knee so
I think that's the bigger issue but you
know sure has he done things that of
could he made his life a little easier
in certain Arenas of course do you
sometimes think we're just like in The
Show Must Go On version of democracy at
this point that nothing kind of works
the way it's supposed to work so we sort
of need these hysterical moments every
few months we need like covid craziness
to keep everyone glued to something to
just keep the machine going we need a
trump indictment to keep because to your
point the economy is not good we're in
this war that we're half not in or we're
in or yeah we're at least funding or do
we even know what the truth is dementia
do you think that sometimes I do think
that a lot that in some ways it's like
we're just in the show must go on the
thing has to the crazy has to keep going
because it's the only thing that unites
us actually whether whether you're on
one side or the other it's just like the
craziness is the driver now as opposed
to hey
Live and Let Live let's get out of the
way everyone calm down well yeah I mean
you really what really unites us anymore
yeah right I mean you've got half of the
country who reveres the flag another
half that wants to burn it you know I
mean like where do you find camaraderie
and unity in in that scenario but you
know I mean I I think the the biggest
hope or you know the the only path
forward really is someone who can get an
office if we hopefully can get someone
to office which you know they're
probably gonna do everything they can to
prevent that from happening but if we
can
um as someone who really wants to
decentralize government I mean that is
the biggest reason why we're here is
just the increased centralization of
everything of government over you know
throughout the entirety of America right
the whole point was supposed to be we're
supposed to be decentralized right and
you've the the you know increased
centralization of the federal government
and then not only that but the increased
centralization of big business I mean
during covid what happens so many small
businesses decimated well small
businesses are more decentralized right
so you have the big grow more powerful
during covet and now with a lot of you
know with banks going under it's the big
Banks getting more powerful and the more
big we have the less too big to fail and
then we make them bigger Yeah the more
big everything is whether it's big
business big government you know big big
Tech whatever it is the less power we
the people have and so I I really
believe that the only path forward if we
want to salvage this Republic if it's
even salvageable at this point is
someone who truly with every fiber in
their being is willing to risk it all to
decentralize everything and just to go
in and to try to gut government from the
inside as much as you possibly can and
that's the path forward what do you
think about this Theory I'm going to
float one oh gosh that I got last night
so David and I don't talk about politics
especially since kids it's mostly about
kids or whatever's going on in life but
we were sitting last night talking about
the Trump thing and he said to me
something that I actually think is
pretty interesting what if the country's
just not ready for sanity yet meaning
that I think most of us want sanity what
we've seen here in Florida is sanity and
it is great and joyous and wonderful and
worthy of celebrating and exporting and
all that stuff but what if for whatever
reason the country itself the 350
million people like we're not ready for
entity so it's almost like we need more
Trump before sanity some something like
that so I personally like we wouldn't
even know what to do with sanity as a
country I mean I think I could I would
think I would like it I dig it well
we're here in Florida where it's saying
that's so it's a disconnect it's right
it's a disconnect between I could get on
board with it Dave I'm just saying like
it's not great for readings I'm on team
sanity yeah
um I mean you know but I I believe that
the right message moving forward is just
simple it's just fixing America yeah
right like it doesn't I think most
Americans whether they want sanity
Insanity whether they're thriving off of
the feeding of the Beast whatever it is
I think if you just say you know what we
should live in a country where you can
find baby Tylenol
baby food uh for your child baby formula
for your child use a gas stove flights
should be able to take off on time
trains shouldn't be crashing at this
rate uh you know you should be able to
pay you should be able to afford to put
gas in your tank and be able to afford
your bills and we're just gonna get back
to a place where America is running
again like just I I think most Americans
just want to know we don't have to live
like this
right we're choosing this path we don't
have to live impoverished we don't have
to live where you can't own anything we
don't have to live where you have to be
in fear of your life walking down the
street like we can get back to America
that runs again right I think that was
David's point last night we're sort of
like addicted to the other thing because
everyone wants that and they're if you
really sat people down and tried to like
really calm everybody down and let's
calm down about Trump and let's not
worry about Biden's dementia but if you
really got everyone to sit there and be
like what do you want it's exactly what
you just laid out there but there's very
few models for that but we do have a
model for it here right I mean we really
do I I don't know I I I maybe I'm just
you know I'm just choosing to believe
this and it's like you know it's just
just me believing this but I I hope I do
believe that things are so bad that
Americans really just want life to be
simpler and easier I do believe that we
are at a place a juncture where people
want that interview like dating too like
when you're younger you date the guy
who's like fun to hang out with and you
know whatever and then when you start
getting older and you want to have kids
you want to get married or like I I not
boring but like I want someone who's
just right stable at 3 A.M
like no you know knows what he's doing
just you know what you're gonna get it's
you know and so I think that is maybe
where you know everything's just been
just more about dating the other guy
that
[Laughter]
20s dating looks different than you know
late 30s dating but but Point bang is
that I I do think that you know
America's had enough of the like crazy
you know I think that people want
um some stability and want life to just
be normal I agree with you and that's
why it's funny because that's why over
the last month or so I've been critical
of trump because I was like wait a
minute wait a minute we have that here
in Florida with the guy that you back
twice and all of that stuff who everyone
you know all the people that suddenly
kind of hate DeSantis
you all loved him two months ago he was
your hero now he's your enemy and I
didn't want Trump I was like make the
case for Trump for Trump I was talking
to the camera like hey Don like make
your case
but that's not the case to destroy
DeSantis in the process because he's the
guy doing that thing yeah I mean like I
don't like the attacks on Governor
DeSantis I mean we both know him we live
here he's an amazing Governor he's a
good person right like Casey DeSantis is
an amazing person like they love their
kids like they are good people and he
has been doing a phenomenal job in the
State of Florida me we're here because
of him and because of the environment
that he has created here right so I
don't like the knocks on Governor
DeSantis he's doing an amazing job he's
a phenomenal Governor you know I think
my biggest concern with Trump and and
you know trying to get reelected is that
he would have four years
versus eight years for for someone else
and I worry that the things that you
have to do particularly with the federal
government and really just trying to
rein in this Beast I don't know if you
can get that done in four years and I
think we're also at a point where again
Republicans are fighting with an arm
behind our back so you know if we don't
get her shot now to get a republican you
know when would it happening I I really
I don't
I don't want to like scare people but I
I genuinely feel that we are moving
close to an authoritarian Nation I mean
you look at a lot of the things that
China did during covid I mean whether
that dissimilar than what people were
trying to do here it exported the virus
and then it exported the Mind virus yeah
and so you know I I don't really know I
mean I think we're we're just moving
closer to being an authoritarian Nation
I I don't really know if people love
democracy as much as they should you
know love living in a constitutional
republic as much as they should or or
maybe they just don't really understand
the difference between you know the
direction that we're heading and where
we could be so
um I don't know where it's going so well
all right sorry I'll handle it don't
worry I'm a professional I had something
for you no no you got nothing to worry
about it we'll come back to you by the
time I finish this sentence well I was
so I was in DC last week it's gonna be
awesome no I have no doubt it the best
thought anyone's ever had you will get
it yeah it's floating like over here now
that's happened to be before on TV where
uh like you are trying to break in a
conversation you've got this thought and
you're like oh man I'm gonna freaking
nail it and then they go to a commercial
break and you look and then they like
and then I've had where someone comes
back and they're like oh Lisa you want
to finish that thought I'm like like I
have like been on my phone like
people I'm like I don't even remember
what I was you know and then like you
just say something and it's like the
lamest you know it's the lamest thing
that's the beauty of cable news it's so
convinced nobody knows what's going on
but you had like but you had a good one
see you you need me to cut to commercial
right now we we don't cut there's no I
can't cut anything you wouldn't even do
it for me I mean I guess we could just
step away from the chairs for just a
moment we could put on some elevators
how awkward would that be that would be
pretty awkward so um one of the first
interviews I did when I was working on a
campaign or it wasn't my first I'd done
a couple at this point but um I thought
the interview was over so I started like
awkwardly walking backwards because I
was trying to get out of the camera shot
and I didn't realize we're still live so
I'm just on camera being like dude do I
just wait real quick and then we'll get
back as long as we're doing first TV
things one of my first TV things ever I
was doing Republican National Convention
coverage when Mitt Romney was going to
be the nominee you know whatever year
that was 2012 I guess and uh I was
supposed to do it was Larry King was
anchoring this thing at Aura TV it was
just he had just left CNN they had this
big studio audience and the air
conditioning broke it was hot as hell in
that room
yeah wait so they put me in a ton of
makeup and they had me waiting behind
this big thick ass curtain so it was I
mean I was freaking melting I could feel
my face melting off I walk out there I
had to write some stand up during the
convention so like five minutes before
I'm working out I'm dripping my face is
falling apart it's all over my shirt
Everything Larry Larry looks at me he
goes live on air yeah and we didn't know
each other at the time we then became
friends after he goes he goes Dave
you're sweating more than hell but
Brooks in Broadcast News and I was like
you're like now I'm really nervous
that's pretty good I wasn't nervous
enough yeah yeah we're getting some uh
some info live here what does that say
breaking the ninth circuit just awarded
awarded Trump 121 thousand dollars in
attorney fees from Stormy Daniels order
just released this is in addition to the
roughly 500k she already owes him and he
left the courtroom apparently a few
minutes ago so Trump's making money on
this thing now it's like what the hell
is going on here I mean this is just
such a shame and we know too like okay
so for either a misdemeanor or a felony
the statue of limitations are already up
for for either right so I mean we know
we I think most people there's even a
CNN poll uh today where I think
something like 52 percent of Americans
thought that this was politically
motivated right it's like they're not
even trying to hide it like it's so
blatantly obvious that that's what's
driving this but do you think that's a
feature not a bug meaning they want
everybody to to think boy it doesn't
matter if 52 are against it it doesn't
matter if most people think it's bogus
it doesn't matter if the statue of
limitations statute of limitations has
passed it's like we're still gonna do it
because that's the thing that people
fear right yeah I mean I do believe that
like the curtain has been pulled right
like there there was I I believe at
least some desire to conceal a lot of
this stuff in the past and then now it's
just laid bare right throughout the the
Trump years right like we know our
government is what I got weaponized
against us there's not even we know that
there's a deep State like there's just
no desire anymore to hide anything so
yeah to your point does Alvin Bragg care
that the statute of limitations are up
does he care that this case is bogus no
I mean he said I was going to indict
Donald Trump when he was running and
that's exactly what he's doing now he
wants that trophy now I remembered the
question I was going to ask you maybe
I'll remember before that when I was in
DC last week we interviewed we reached
out to like every Republican you could
think of we got yeses from literally
everybody except for Mitch McConnell who
was in the hospital yeah it was a very
packed couple days the interviews are
still coming out no resp no well no no
yeses from Democrats Rashida Talib did
say no but everyone else just ignored
our emails but one thing that I did what
did you say pretty please did we say
pretty please in that email I think
there was a pretty please in there uh
but it could have been why but
um one of the questions that I asked
every Republican is to your point
if we can't work with these people
anymore if they've just made their their
positions clear and they're never going
to stop and they'll be chopping off our
kids genitals and they'll be teaching
racism in school and they'll be
arresting political if they're just
gonna keep going and my suspicion at
this point is that they will
then then what does that separation look
like like I keep thinking like man I
lived in Cali for eight years I loved it
for six years it was high taxes whatever
but I there I did love something about
it I have no desire to go back there
anymore I don't feel any camaraderie
with it the governor is a maniac Los
Angeles is a dump San Francisco is a is
a dystopian nightmare it's like what
what does connect us anymore and maybe
it do you think we really have to be in
a way
you know what I don't mind not being
connected to other Americans like I'm
fine with I mean I have to go up to New
York for work but like if I didn't I
would be fine with like never stepping
foot in the state again or not ever
going to California again not having to
have conversations with those people but
they won't leave us alone right right so
that's the problem if we were just
allowed to like true federalism everyone
just leave us alone you know get off our
back let Florida do Florida like we
would all be in peace but that's the
problem is they won't like we would
allow you know California but they will
not allowed does not want anything from
California California wants things from
Florida yeah like they just won't leave
us be so I I don't know I mean I really
like what connects me with someone you
know a liberal in New York City I don't
know outside of unless I knew them for
personal reasons from you know work or
family or something like that I don't
know so probably not on it is the Silver
Lining you think that they're just
exposing themselves so fast in real time
right now that that may be that curtain
and we're going to look behind it and
it's going to be this little guy and not
the all-powerful odds and then and that
hopefully more and more people do wake
up but then you know there's all sorts
of you know you could vote in California
without IDs etc etc I mean I I do
believe that there are more Americans
than not who view a lot of this stuff as
nonsense uh like you know for instance
like I think a big issue is the
transgender stuff and what they're
trying to do to kids right I think it
says everything about a country and the
way that you treat children
and you know we have a portion which I
actually do believe is a minority of the
population that are encouraging children
to change their genders encouraging
their children to mutilate their body if
I was cutting myself my friends would
say my God Lisa let's talk what's going
on and we are encouraging this to happen
particularly you know in children who
are probably going to regret it one day
and probably gonna have hatred for their
parents for allowing them to go through
it so lawsuits against their parents and
a whole bunch of other stuff but I do
believe you know I hope that the
majority of Americans look at that and
they say this is wrong I actually don't
believe it but I think people have been
so brow beaten and I really do think
social media has a huge role in that
where there's just this mounting peer
pressure like even Executives and
corporations and companies I I you know
are basically being held hostage I
Believe by a small group of people who
are vocal online on social media and so
I am just hoping that that silent
majority you know will go out and try to
vote and try to make a difference you
know I I think people really do need to
show up because again I think they're
going to try everything they can to try
to stifle or chances of winning
isn't it weird though that then you know
we all think of red waves coming and
it's like man that was not a red wave
like Republicans need to get the house
okay that was great and by the way when
I was there last week like the
Republicans I think are a little
different from the uniparty thing I
really do think McCarthy and some of
these guys Jim Jordan and Byron Donalds
and now JD Vance and the Senate like
they are a different breed I really do
believe they are they're and that's also
what's so disappointing about today
because they're doing some good things
there and they're defunding things and
everything else but now all the
attentions back on Trump as opposed to
the good things that they're doing
defunding those 87 000 IRS agents Etc
but I believe though that the 2024
election because it will be a
presidential election I don't really
know if it'll be as much based off of
what Congress did as it will be who's
the nominee what their message is and
what they're going to do for the country
so I really think that what will be dry
saving that election is going to be the
presidential election but you know sure
it's good to be able to look at things
and say we've done this we've
accomplished you know this that in the
other but I you know I think the driving
force of the presidential election will
be you know the presidential election
and look I was one of those people with
the midterm I I thought a big red wave
was coming because if you look at uh
just historically like all the factors
were there I've worked on previous
elections that this had been even 2016
if this had been you know 2010 when I
was there for the wave election in 2010
I think we got 63 seats in the house if
my memory serves me am I correct I'm a
little tired today but um but point
being is so I've been there when waves
have happened and so I really felt like
that was coming I do believe that the
mail-in ballot thing has completely
changed the game in the sense of I mean
even if you look at Pennsylvania by the
time that the fetterman Oz debate had
happened you already had you know I can
remember I think it was like 30 it was
like almost a half or whatever a mail-in
ballots had already been submitted at
this point so you know what the point is
before the debate before the debate had
happened disaster for fetterman who I
mean fetterman said good night before
the debate started like that's really
all you need to know I mean it did not
go well yeah he said good night before
and I mean that would be like me coming
on the show and being like good night
you'd be like well what are we going to
do for the next day I guess we're going
to do this backwards do we have more
Clips like how are we going to get
through this you're like it's not good
but like when I've worked on campaigns
in the past there were a lot of
opportunities to try to change the
trajectory of the race you know you
could find Opportunities to to try to to
save it to try to you know Salvage a
couple points here and there right there
there were there were moments of
momentum that you could capture now with
mail-in ballads you can't do that yeah
those are few and far between and
probably meaningless at this point
because it's not about earning votes
it's about getting ballots and so we as
Republicans in a party really need to
wise up to that and to follow suit you
know in the states where you can do
ballot harvesting we need I mean
obviously everyone needs to do it
legally but in the states where it is
legal to ballot Harvest and do some of
these different things we need to play
ball and so it's the same thing is that
also one of the weird things and I said
this right when Trump announced that one
of the weird things about the campaign
in general I know we're this doesn't
excuse any of the nonsense going on
right now but if Trump honestly believes
that the election was stolen which I
believe he believes and I was at the
2000 mules Premiere and he gave a big
speech and obviously he's endlessly
talked about it if he really believes
that it was stolen
in a weird way it doesn't make sense to
run again unless you've done something
about that and I don't know that he's
done exactly what you're calling for
there he can't do it he's not present
anymore you need Secretary of States in
the individual you need the secretary of
state of Pennsylvania to do something
about it but they have no interest in
doing it because their guys are winning
I mean but I think even you know putting
aside like ballots and and all of that
aspect of his concerns of the election
you could even just looking at the the
disallowing and the stopping of the
hunter Biden story right like Media
Matters there's been all these different
pollsters who have done research showing
that the Dynamics of the election truly
would have changed if more Americans had
known about the hunter Biden story and
some of these Biden scandals so even
with that you could say that you know it
wasn't fair right so I do think that
there are some validity to his concerns
that he's making even setting aside some
of those other arguments I'm not
actually not even denying I mean yeah
I'm just saying that you got to do
something about it again if you're going
to run again right I I think that you
need to and I believe he has said some
of this and you know in Florida where we
allow for early voting and we're you
know you have election Integrity here
right so or ID yeah right yeah I mean so
they're making sure that the people are
who they say they are who are going out
and voting and then they pursue cases
where it's not
um but yeah I mean I think he has said
that now you know we should be doing or
I do believe that was a big mistake in
the 2020 election of not you know either
I think the first and foremost was
legally trying to challenge those things
before they they took hold uh you know
challenging it on beforehand right you
know challenging it before you know as
the secretary of state was trying to to
change these things unilaterally or what
have you whether it was it you know
whoever it was you know secretary of
state state legis whatever the governor
you know going in and proactively trying
to preempt some of these things that you
know took hold that were questionable
with you know not like Pennsylvania not
looking at matching signatures and
things of that nature trying to get in
beforehand and fighting those battles
ahead of time I think would have been
more prudent
um but you know once they took hold you
kind of have to play the the game as
it's laid out you know and unfortunately
we're in this era now where it's sort of
this new frontier in politics where we
are having to to deal with male and
ballots I mean we are you know it's sort
of appended the political process but
you can't change anything until you win
and we can't win unless we play the game
as it's already laid out and it's it's
an unfair game I hate the game it's a
stupid game I want to hit like all that
you know if you're playing Monopoly I
want to just go like this to it and you
know say this sucks but or you could be
a Democrat and you just keep printing
money
or you just leave exactly uh but you
know it it is what it is right and you
kind of have to just deal in reality so
what do you what do you think's gonna
happen like if I know no one wants to be
in the prediction game but you're pretty
good about this stuff I don't know I was
until the midterms and then because I
was really good I was talking about
Macomb County Michigan in 2016 ahead of
the presidential election before I was
hearing other people on TV talking about
Macomb County Michigan talking about
Trump's path through the Rust Belt on
Fox News head of the 2016 election even
on a special report I only gave Hillary
a slight advantage and I almost gave
them 50 50 but I was talking to people
in the green room and they're acting
like I was crazy so it got in my head I
should have just been like stuck to my
gut and gave them 50 50 shot
um can I Pat myself on the back too just
for a little yeah yeah
I think it was the day before the the
2016 election and and I said I thought
Trump could win I really I just felt I
was like everything's so out of whack
social media is so nice wait let me just
pause for one sec because they're giving
me something right now uh this is
breaking prosecutors asked for a January
2024 trial in New York for Donald Trump
the next hearing is set for December 4th
2023 like this is never going that's
what I'm saying The Show Must Go On they
have to keep doing now we have to talk
about this till December and then till
January middle of the election will the
guy be able to to travel to campaign
they just wanted to go and go and go and
go I mean it's smart too right because
it people aren't going to be it's the
shiny object yeah you know look over
here don't look at the fact you can't
pay your bills don't look at the fact
that you might get murdered in this
street when walking down there there's a
scary artery I know I have friends in DC
who won't go get gas now because they're
terrified of getting carjacked because
because the there are so many
carjackings that are taking place
they're genuinely scared for their life
to even just go get gas in in Washington
DC uh so it is a shiny object you know
don't pay attention to the things that
genuinely impact your life let's all you
know pay attention to This Witch Hunt
that is happening in New York City and
it is important I believe because we're
talking about the rule of law we're
talking about precedent setting things
that's never before in history has this
happened and ultimately sadly what this
will probably do is then open the door
for D.A liberal DA's across the country
to say now we're going to be weaponizing
the law even further against
conservatives conservative candidates
whoever else it may be what do you think
of the you I keep hearing this on
Twitter mostly but I think there's some
legitimacy to it a lot of conservative
type pundits saying well now this is
what we have to do too meaning we have
to weaponize the DA's and it's like all
right well I'll just go to hell together
like I get it I get it you have to start
scaring some demo Democrats right like
there's many things Hillary paid for the
Steele dossier that's what literally the
entire Russia collusion hoax was based
on uh bleached the the hard drives like
all of that stuff there's some
criminality in there somewhere but like
to me it's just like all right so we
will all go to hell together like that's
that's where it will perpetually take us
so I've gone back and forth in my mind a
lot about this
uh keep coming back to the fact that we
might all just be going to hell anyways
I mean I hope I go to I blame God so
you're not like yeah
dear God if you're listening
like to go there you know but uh but you
know we're probably already on that path
anyways and I I think that we've reached
a point where for the left their God is
government it's power and the only thing
they respond to is power and so in some
respect maybe the only thing that they
will understand is realizing that then
they're going to be vulnerable as well
right I mean look at the amount of
crimes the Biden family has likely
committed you know so if they're going
to be pursuing these types of charges
against Trump then they're opening
themselves up to similar vulnerability
vulnerabilities if not more because
based off of all the investigations
against Donald Trump they're going to
get him potentially on maybe not even a
misdemeanor that they're trying to
elevate to a felony's most investigated
man in America and this is what they can
come up with I guarantee if you put
these kind of resources yes exactly
towards Joe Biden my God right what you
would be able to find or any of the
Democrats and it's usually Democrats
it's Republicans too but the amount of
Democrats that go into office Worth next
to nothing Barack Obama was was a
community organizer and a senator who
now has a 12 million dollar house on the
you know in Martha's Vineyard right on
the water so he's not too worried about
climate change either it's like where
did all that money come yeah also where
did those concerns about yeah or he also
has 30 Acres there and for some reason
when they brought those like 12 people
from Martha's Vineyard when Florida
shipped them over there he didn't offer
them one acre you could fit 12 people
hilarious because it was like peace love
like you know we love people like
coexist like you know bring the migrants
and then they get there no one's illegal
except if you're in more than yeah and
they're like okay guys like you don't
have to go home but you can't stay here
you know like ship them off and buses
and then they're there to hug them and
just give them a little tap on the butt
and get them going you know so that was
uh obviously you know DeSantis was
brilliant for that because he sort of
showed their cards that it's all a farce
they don't really care about migrants
and you know they don't really care
about people in general
um but uh yeah I got I got one more for
you at least okay I think we're out of
time but wait we got wait we got one
more thing uh Trump was temporarily
placed in a holding cell between two
other inmates being processed for petty
theft I mean it's just it's just a farce
and so silly and nonsensical and someone
probably snapped a cell phone picture
that we'll see of that
um one more for you and then we'll we'll
do this again where we can get to talk
about yourself did I pass you guys we're
gonna have her back on what was what's
my name wow all thumbs up at once that's
rare I thought I saw one down then I
realized it was up
[Laughter]
that's what I want to ask you about Lisa
Booth you're always smiling you're
always smiling you're always laughing I
I know so many people on cable news that
are you know they can somehow turn it on
for the camera but they're like
miserable people so many of the pundits
like you know me this is basically me
now it's like 100 you know but I do
think when the camera's on there's like
you you were just two percent or
something like that like I think there's
a there's a or you're like I don't know
what to do with my eyes I always feel
like that your hands no they like on the
show I'm like where do I put I've been
shifting a lot here yeah I'm like but
like but you are the same person either
way and and I think you know I think
mostly it's usually conservative
hopefully positive yeah no that's what I
mean but conservative women get away on
TV and in real life what aren't you
supposed to be angry and and bitter
about all of this and and upset and all
that stuff no I mean of course I could
like I have honestly I'm not gonna lie
to the audience at home it's been like
sort of a downer the past few days right
because you I love this country and it
makes me sad what's happening I don't
have kids yeah I like when I do have
kids if I ever get around to it at the
rate I'm going you know what kind of
country am I going to be raising them in
I mean that truly or where if I have
grandkids what kind of you know that it
genuinely worries me so like I have felt
it but I also bleed you know look I love
life I love my family I have great
friends you know and so there's so much
Beauty in life as well and so I tried to
do my best of not letting all the
negative negate all the positive and not
living your life because I mean how
tragic would that be if not only do they
put us through all this crap but then
also deprive us of happiness or joy in
our own lives right and so it's you know
I believe that we have to fight these
things that's why we were both so
outspoken during the covid stuff and I
don't think we should back down or or be
cowards right we need to be Brave and
Bold and trying to push back a lot of
this stuff but we also have to live our
lives and you ever think it's just like
too late also like I think that's
something
[Laughter]
we just we just guys went dark so it is
off myself no no no
no no no no no Dave I'm a little worried
my heart just
you can rent one of mine if you want or
something
um no but like that Uganda you know
because I think it's too like I've gone
down this yeah fighting for the things I
believe in so deeply that like I
couldn't turn around now there's just
nothing I could do I could never face
myself if I didn't continue the fight
you know no and it's hard I mean like I
genuinely think it makes it hard with
dating it makes it hard with your life
because it's
you know look how polarizing politics
are today look how polarizing covid was
and still is today so it is challenging
when we are so outspoken and when you
know all of someone has to do is Google
your name and all this stuff pops up
right and then they form an opinion of
you so it makes and I I think that's in
part what the left ones as well right
they're trying to make social priyas out
of people who don't agree with them who
won't submit who won't just go along
with the program and so you know I think
that part does make life challenging but
I would rather be a social Pariah and
you know have people who I thought maybe
love me turn their backs on me then have
to live with being a coward every single
day of my life you know what would be I
don't think I would be able to respect
myself look at myself in the mirror or
or take any pride in the way I live my
life
if I'm a coward
Lisa I have only one more word for you
oh
starts with a t ends with an a we're
gonna go get some right now
tequila
Lisa Booth ladies and gentlemen all
right guys we're back hey guys 11 A.M
tomorrow
foreign